[Music]
603 right now and tomorrow marks 20
years since the 9 11 terror attacks
nearly 3 000 people died when four
planes were hijacked two crashed into
the twin towers in new york one into the
pentagon in washington and passengers on
that fourth plane stopped the hijackers
and crashed the jet into a field in
rural pennsylvania president joe biden
is expected to attend tomorrow's
memorials at all three locations
this morning the valley paying tribute
to victims that were killed in that
tragedy one of the victims was a palo
verde high school teacher barbara
edwards hector mejia live this morning
with the ceremonies that are happening
at local schools including one in her
honor hector good morning
good morning students across the
district are holding ceremonies this
morning the first one starts here at
valley high school in less than 30
minutes the jrotc will host that
ceremony right here in front of the
school ccsd lost one of its own in the
tragedy and later on this morning over
at palo verde high school students will
hold the annual ceremony honoring
foreign language teacher barbara edwards
this is the september 11th memorial on
campus honoring all of the victims as
well as the teacher's legacy
edwards was on the plane that crashed
into the pentagon during previous
ceremonies we've heard from one of her
longtime friends gail fay
everything reminds me that she's still
here with us in spirit and
i loved i loved her very much she's just
a real special person she's still
still my best friend she's always in my
heart
those who knew edward say she was an
outgoing person and always had a sense
of humor the french and german language
teacher was an advocate for foreign
travel she was 58 years old the events
are not open to the public we are
standing by for this event to start at 6
30 this morning we'll bring it to you
live as soon as it begins here on 8 news
now reporting live hector mejia back to
you hector thank you very much they have
those ceremonies they have ever since
the tragedy so we'll have that coming up
in about half an hour there are other
local events to commemorate 9 11 at 8
o'clock this morning there's a ceremony
at nellis air force base at nine first
responders will participate in a 9 11
tower climb over at the strat las vegas
fire and rescue holds its annual tolling
of the bells at 6 45 tomorrow morning a
retired new york firefighter will sing
the national anthem at fire station 5
that's near valley view in charleston
the i-team is also sharing stories all
week long about 9 11 during our 6 in the
evening newscast and a reminder that we
have a special 911 newscast tomorrow
night at 6 30.